ce soir quatre couples de danseurs je
vais faire partie des danseurs parce que
j'avais envie de danser
je vais donc cela dure je vais donc
choisi à ce qu'on peut m'amener à
microsoft vous plaît c'est à dire un
micro avec une sucette au tour merci les
chéris chasser les choisir trois
personnes du public se font livrer être
le jury de notre danse est clair mal
léché rice et le dos avec hermann je
vais lancer le générique de danse
éclaire mal et vous allez voir
l'animateur va arriver puisque ce n'est
pas moi qui va animer cette séquence
c'est l'excellentissime celui qui va
nous faire les quatre tirs tout à
l'heure jean luc lemoine
eh bien j'aimerais oui oui parce que
j'avais compétents oui on va ici mais là
il n'a pas l'air sur glace si sûr de moi
voir est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
accueillir nos premiers candidats au 8
août à saisir en retrait oui c'est parti
pour danse avec leurs marques
sur un tango knox in guinea il sa
partenaire qui nagent avec joe kelly
mais l'embellie
à l'aller
un point
ça me
on l'a vu dans son regard de leur bébé
qu'on a mis les gants
comment ça va au niveau de la vision vos
courriers maintenus très bas et florian
sont super bien sorti je suis fan de
khadija chérif avait contraint de lâcher
et najwa très beau couple
ils vont très bien ensemble les jurés
ont attribué leur note me veil s'est pas
apitoyé c'est un set
lorient
un joli nez et najwa way
jamais je sais qu'il faut partir merci
sur un jive qui est une danse très
difficile paraît-il il fasse sublime à
gâteau proulx et le sud et benjamin
castaldi
ac
k
alors on est d'accord on juge la danse
par la crise d'épilepsie de berges a pu
mener une agression
alors voilà tout donné la mairie un joli
on juge et agathe et benjamins ça c'est
bien dissocier 5,5 et enfin nageoires
on accueille le troisième couple sur une
longue bada le livre officiel épisode
joey starr gilles verdez et sa
partenaire
ludivine rhétorique
les bateaux étrangers
alors je rappelle le jury devait
normalement assister à une longue
bataille de la lambada peu distante de
l'histoire de la lambada
qu'en avez-vous pensé mireille un joli 7
1 7 6
les sexy dont six concernent aussi
possible en faire mais vous avez regardé
que ludivine en fait c'est en le
couplant un généreux pour les sections à
travers ces couples formés vous voilà
frolon beaucoup qu'en avez-vous pensé
moi je leur mets un très beau neuf parce
que j'étais ainsi garder je m'attendais
vraiment inquiet
comment la crise de benjamin mais
finalement pas fait d'ici là ces
récitations est ce que ma joie est
d'accord avec ça bat pour que gilles
soit ou si zen franchement à mes
chapeaux merci si la boudeuse oui je
sais vous invite
nous avons passé aux quatre nageoires
pour ceux qui auraient manqué l'émission
je vous rappelle et n'ont aucune
compétence donc ils sont légitimes
il reste deux couples candidats et il
vous demande d'accueillir tout de suite
sur un roc
le séduisant mais salle jean michaud
mère et sa partenaire qui a une entorse
au gros orteil
mais qui est quand même portraitiste
non
quand on va danser comme ça si on avait
un taser et bars le couple s'est
disloqué pendant les pendant la danse
quant à penser notre jury mireuil mais
j'ai adoré franchement à quoi
non attendez s est d en chine sort bien
céder en chine je vous rappelle que
c'est une danse de couple
non oui ils se sont déhanchés je
n'oublie pas michel je t'oublie pas et
jean-michel à michel lahmi cher les gens
michel quint d'autres non mon général
que milano de 10 ans 10 à y est gentil
mais alors reconduit à qu'isabelle qui a
dans ses bas la moitié des médecins
c'est vrai que c'est isabelle qui a tout
donné
ce qui est formidable c'est que michel
un moment il a lâché l'affairé et on
applaudit alléger ma leçon dans ses pas
longtemps d'accord et les nageoires car
ils ont géré et surtout isabelle isa
donc pour moi je donne un petit choix
il revient maintenant notre frère
nicolas
le couple vedette mesdames et messieurs
jo de danse orientale le prince de la
télévision est le roi du paf en général
cyril hanouna et son partenaire qui
pourra jamais dire la même chose
non soyons réalistes et son partenaire
matthieu delormeau
bon
c
mais est-ce que ça remonte au temps
pascal on a vu les gouttes comme un joli
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire un point sur
les scores avant nos notes et je vais
dire le cadeau j'ai déjà voit bien
gênante l'équipe gagnante pour l'instant
partir en week end à 2-2 pour trois
jours les deux les deux gagnants c'est
qu'il est gagnant pour l'instant maxime
et clé en 7,7
donc ils ont perdu à guetter benji six
ans dans l'espoir sur le truc c'est aux
primaires si gilles et ludivine 8 sur 10
et il avait les jambes aisselles huit
fois sur dix je ne cherche pas convoquer
l'ensemble mais tout se joue sur cette
note
messieurs ministre eut juré du patient
de vouloir gagner moins le sort du
week-end de syrie donnent même mathieu
darnaud est entre vos mains
les jurys ont décidé de donner
quelle note mireille 6 1 mais wright tu
peux te brosser pour ses jours la
semaine prochaine
c'est ainsi que j'aime bien dire hey
elle dit la vérité is a été aussi franc
raté les modes la main mais j'ai envie
d'avoir les infos sur ce week-end là
donc je leur dise
quelques lignes 10 et 6 me contre 6,6
ça fait pour l'instant moyenne de 8
ouais vous va se jouer sur nos joueurs
alors moi j'aime beaucoup mathieu mais
j'adore cyril et vu que ça m'a rappelé
un petit peu le pays
donc je n'en ai dit tu es ce que vous
avez donc une moyenne de 8 bien ça
à ce jour on part en trois jours et
c'est m regardez ces magnifiques vous
partez à paris